so without any further ado we'll bring
Fred to the stage
fred is currently the harry and norman
chandler professor and chair of the
department of communication at stanford
his books two of which are here for sale
tonight and in the back and of course
they'll be signing them afterwards and
and hockey hawking them with with
without with no shame yes as as he well
should and so i don't think i need to
say much more other than to say he is he
is someone who's looking at a near
history for us which is a great service
that we don't always get a the
perspective of a talent and a perceptive
mind like fred so thanks for that let's
give him a round of applause and hear
what he has to say thank you thank you
michael appreciate it and thank yous and
ER for having me um thank you long now
thank you interval and thank you all for
being here if some of you are scholars
and book writers you'll know that you
spend a lot of time alone in your room
and then every so often it's absolutely
thrilling to get out and actually talk
with folks and so it's it's a thrill for
me to be here tonight I'm gonna walk us
through kind of a complicated and long
history I'm gonna walk us through
starting ultimately in the early 40s and
the question that animates a lot of my
work is what was the counterculture and
what has it changed since it arrived
I've been involved for a long time about
10 years and kind of tracking both the
roots of the counterculture and its
impact on the tech world especially
today and ironically I'm it's it's a
little bit odd to be here my PhD
dissertation was actually about Stewart
Brand so it's a little odd to be here in
this room but also also really exciting
so let's go back to the counterculture
oh we just lost a slide there we go
great okay so this is 1957 this is the
march on the Pentagon I've been a
journalist for about 10 years
I was born in 61 and I returned to
graduate school in the mid
1990s when I got there I discovered that
there was a kind of consistent story
about how the 1960s worked in that story
told mostly by historians who were
themselves children of the 1960s or at
least young adults in the 1960s the the
counterculture was a single movement
that kind of rose up in technicolor
glory against a closed-down hierarchical
emotionally constrained heteronormative
mostly white cold war America it's a
very powerful idea and it's it's one
that I used to think was true I don't
think that's what happened anymore and
my mission today is to walk you through
what I think actually happened I'm gonna
make three cases I'm gonna make first
the case that the idea that we associate
most quintessentially with the 1960s the
idea that the personal is political did
not in fact emerge there but rather
emerged I mean you can say it our
immersion lots of places 19th century
romanticism or others but one of the
places that emerged most centrally was
the 1940s visit we can draw kind of a
direct line I'm gonna try to draw it
tonight between personality theory in
the 1940s the hippies of the 1960s and
in many ways what we imagined the
hackers of our own time to be the second
thing that I've been told about the
counterculture was that a hit stood
against mainstream military industrial
culture that turns out not to be true
either it is true that there was a
tremendous amount of tumult and
rebellion against particular militarized
military culture against the Army in
particular but there was also a very
deep embrace of the guiding ideals of
military industrial culture it's
collaborative research culture its
emphasis on small scale technologies for
transformative purposes and above all
its guiding intellectual dogma
cybernetics we're actually sitting in a
room that owes some of its design to
that Allegiance finally I'm gonna make a
third case having walked from the 40s to
the 60s to the present I'm going to
argue that the bohemian modes of
organizing gathering collaborating that
emerged most visibly in the 1960
our guiding the rise of a new mode of
manufacturing today and so that's the
case I'm gonna try to walk us from the
1940s to the present and try to do it in
a reasonably quick way probably talk for
about 45 minutes if you have questions
of fact as I move through please jump
right in if you have conceptual
questions please hold those because I
think we'll have some time to get right
into that after the talk good to go
all right great onward all right so this
is what I've been up to for the last 10
almost 15 years now I've been involved
in a kind of long long history and it's
a history that began with a PhD
dissertation on the counterculture and
on Stewart Brand and I wrote that book
it became a book started as a
dissertation became a book it's
available in the back there'll be two
advertisements that was the first one
the second the second one come a little
bit later okay
that book tried to show how
countercultural folks associated with
Stewart and with the whole earth network
had a real impact on how we imagined the
Internet as it emerged into the world
the argument of that book was that the
commune world of the 1960's set the
conceptual terms by which we came to
understand the Internet and the world
wide web as an electronic frontier and
it's very proud of it as an argument um
one of the things that I found most
strange when I was writing that book was
flipping open the first pages of the
Whole Earth Catalog and seeing people
like Norbert Wiener in the mix now
Stewart and his then-wife Louis had
created the Whole Earth Catalog to
provide tools for people headed back to
the land now you know you might think
that what you would want most of all
when you headed back to the land was a
tractor or a hoe but in fact the whole
if catalog was about 80% books and those
books often dealt with systems theory
with cybernetics they were written by
Norbert Wiener by Buckminster Fuller I
was surprised because I had been told
that the counterculture had nothing to
do with the 40's and yet the deeper I
got into Stewart brands life and the
life of folks around him the more I saw
that he and his friends were reading
people from the 40s they were reading
Erich Fromm they were reading Margaret
Mead Gregory Bateson these folks are all
intellectual leaders
from the world war ii era and so as I
began to think about what I wanted to do
for a new book I just kept on working
backwards and I ended up doing and this
is the second advertisement heads up I
ended up doing another book which I'll
talk a lot about tonight the Democratic
surround and in that book I returned to
a 1940's that I never knew it's a 1940's
in which intellectuals sociologists
social scientists government officials
are pursuing a radically anti-racist
agenda a radically Pro sexual preference
diversity agenda and the development of
multimedia forms that are explicitly
designed to resist the psychology of
fascism those efforts in the 1940s I
argue set the stage for the psychedelic
revolution of the 1960s and that's the
theme of this book tonight I'm gonna
talk take take the toll trajectory and
take us up a little bit into the present
but let's go back to the past first so
this is the late 1930s in the late 1930s
and you know arguably foreshadow some of
the issues that we're facing now the
American government had a problem
problem was this Germany Italy Japan had
become fascist states in the late 1930s
America was still kind of a poky
third-world ish sort of country and it
thought of Japan I thought of Germany
and of France particularly as the homes
of the highest culture in the world and
so American intellectuals particularly
but also political leaders journalists
were shocked to think that Germany had
fallen for this crazy short mustachioed
former clerk Adolf Hitler how was it
that the most cultured nation in the
land had gone fascist and there were a
lot of answers in play some of the
answers had to do with vimar and
economic chaos but they were actually in
the minority the bigger set of answers
the more common set of answers had to do
with mass media there was a terrible
fear that mass media had literally
turned the Germans into fascists and it
had happened in one of two ways either
Hitler and his cohort were in fact
insane
have managed to broadcast their insanity
through the wires through the radio
through the cinema into the mass of
Germans who were hearing them or there
was something about one-to-many
broadcast structure that literally
forced you to somehow turn off your
reason
open up your unconscious and render
yourself vulnerable to a single leader
you know today these sound may be a
little bit wacky but they didn't sound
as wacky in that time and that's partly
because the media themselves were newer
but it's also because fascism was a very
real and living possibility in America
at this time I didn't know before I did
this book and you may not know as well
that in 1939 twenty-two thousand
Americans met in Madison Square Garden
under an American banner and a Nazi flag
and under a banner hanging from the
ceiling that said stop Jewish domination
of Christian America they celebrated
fascism in 1939 after Hitler went into
Germany and after Hitler would into
Poland after he went into Poland a
thousand Americans marched down East
86th Street in New York carrying
swastikas and American flags wearing
their own brown shirt uniforms and they
were not booed their pictures of both
these events in my book it's simply
astonishing father Coughlin some of you
may have heard of him a demagogue from
the late 1930s had three and a half
million listeners every week he
celebrated things like the protocols of
the Elders of Zion and Nazi tract
program Nazi tract
he had according to Gallup polls seventy
percent of his listeners agreeing with
his views every week that's three
million people every week in support of
fascism my guess is you probably
remember Humphrey Bogart the actor yeah
oh yeah okay just let's just shout out
some movie some Humphrey Bogart movies
just give me any old title Casablanca
good all right this is like the classic
what African Queen good keep going
Maltese Falcon excellent others haven't
have not okay great
nobody has mentioned the Black Legion
1937 very popular movie
Humphrey Bogart starred as a black shirt
at America
fascist who kills his polish neighbor
and regrets it
in the immortal words of the novelist
Sinclair Lewis there was an
understanding in the late 30s as again
there probably is today that it can
happen here and so the challenge facing
American government officials and
American intellectuals as World War two
got underway was how do we do propaganda
on our own people to encourage them to
resist fascism without turning them into
fascists now there's actually a faction
in Roosevelt's circle who I discovered
archival II really thought Joseph
gurbles was the bomb they wanted to
imitate Joseph Goebbels propaganda
techniques and they told Roosevelt look
don't worry about it they may turn
authoritarian for a bit but we can bring
them back later dead serious okay there
was another group though and led in part
by Margaret Mead who you see here the
anthropologist who had a very different
vision and I mean enormous Lee I was
ignorant excited to get to know her and
the community around her in 1940-41 Mead
and 59 other leading intellectuals
formed something called the committee
for national morale these folks the
folks who did this were Arthur up and
Pope and our historian
let's see Gordon Allport a psychologist
Mead her then-husband Gregory Bateson
and these folks were social scientists
who were very committed to sort of two
ideas one about media one about the way
the world worked let's start with the
way the world worked they were some of
them students of Franz boas the
anthropologist and they believed that
every culture on the planet had a modal
personality and the the job of media and
the job of the family was to train
citizens to reach that modal personality
to be that kind of person they explained
the rise of fascism in Germany in part
as a function of an authoritarian
personality type that lived in Germany
and that had been invoked by Hitler and
they said that what we needed to do was
develop and cultivate a Democratic
personality and we needed to develop
media that would do that now a
Democratic personality in their view was
war
open collaborative it was explicitly
anti-racist it was not only tolerant of
sexual different sexual preference
difference but embraced all different
kinds of people meet herself was
bisexual as were many in her circle
homosexuality bisexuality were far more
than tolerated they were sort of a
normal part of life and in her world and
that's important to know
so they hoped to develop a new kind of
morale they wanted to develop a morale
centered on personality and they were
going to develop a new mode of media to
do it let's start with the personality
part this is Gordon Allport of the here
is Gordon Allport you know it's funny
sometimes when you look back at the past
and you see people in very conservative
suits with no hair you think wow must
have been a conservative far from it
this is a man who got on horseback and
met with the Boston City police and
tried to tried to train them in
resisting racism he's actually kind of a
radical guy two words here that we need
to pay special attention to 1942 in a
democracy every personality can be a
citadel of resistance to tyranny for the
folks in committee for national morale
it was the personality the center of the
of the person the Democratic personality
that was the source of political
resistance this is an idea I just want
to flag this right now it's gonna come
back to haunt us personality is going to
become the basis of an expressive
politics in the 60s it's also going to
become the basis of Donald Trump's power
coming back to that the second piece
it's really important is that they've
distrusted hierarchy they did not want
to see top-down hierarchy they did not
want to see one too many structures
because those four characteristic of
fascism they wanted to organize
Americans by coordinating them by
gathering them together think Facebook
Facebook okay here too is one of the
origin points of the logic that governs
the world of search and social media
thing about the Committee for national
Morales they were you know they were
great social scientists but they were
lousy media builders they actually sent
a proposal I found this in the archives
it cracked me up
they sent a proposal to missus
Rockefeller who funded the the Museum of
Modern Art in New York for an extra
building they wanted to build a building
with pictures everywhere sounds from all
sides smoke blowing in and statues that
talked about America it was kind of a
goofy idea but the essential thing that
they were getting at was that they
believed that if you could surround
individuals with media with images with
sounds you could free them to practice
choosing using their perceptions to
choose in such a way that they would
become more democratic their psyches
would literally become more democratic
because they had to practice choosing
things together now committee for
national morale couldn't make media
fortunately for them in 1937 a group of
Bauhaus refugees came to New York and
among them was Herbert Beier whose work
you see here on the screen Herbert Beier
was the Bauhaus typographer in the early
part of the 20th century he went on to
help found the Aspen Institute and all
the Aspen culture that we know today but
in 1937 he was a guy who needed a job he
came here with a highly developed
understanding of multi-image display he
had been designing museum exhibitions in
Germany and in France and other
countries surrounding viewers with
images and furniture and
three-dimensional objects because he and
his Bauhaus colleagues believed that
that would make viewers more able to
resist industrial society when he got to
the States it was very easy for him to
repurpose that technique and argue for
American audiences that the same
technique could now produce Democratic
citizens citizens able to reduce able to
fight back against fascism his designs
became the basis of a new mode that I've
called the Democratic surround it's a
new genre it's an aesthetic that emerges
in 1942 and travels all the way down to
our own time this is the first time it
ever appeared in public as far as I can
tell this is a 1942 propaganda
exhibition at the Museum of Modern Art
and it's designed by Herbert Beier and
Edward Steichen the famous photographer
who would go on to design family of man
the same principals now if you look at
the slides right you can see that there
are images of lots of different sizes
you know and it looks very
propagandistic you can see here there's
a man who says ah war by God they asked
for it by God they'll get it down here
you see Tojo giggling while Pearl Harbor
burns this is very much a kind of
propaganda exhibition but that's not
what stirred viewers it's really
interesting I've looked at all the
reviews of this show that I can find
there were about 80,000 people who saw
the show in its first in the eight weeks
of its run and what struck them was the
way in which the multimedia experience
called forth a new way of seeing the
show one one reviewer said this show
does not mold viewers opinions for that
word smacks of fascism
it was the display mode itself that most
excited audiences they imagined that
they were finally free to move among
these images to walk down the road to
victory with whomever they liked seeing
images on the wall identifying with the
images that animated them the most
ignoring others they felt in control of
their own experience and yet unified in
their love of America and it was a
feeling that ended up defining a genre I
go into the history of the genre at
great length and with great pictures
third advertisements re in in the book
the Democratic surround but for our
purposes tonight what I want to point
out is simply that the surround traveled
from that World War Two moment all the
way into the 1960s particularly the
psychedelic environments of the 1960s
down two roads one road and I'll show
you an example of this in a moment was
propaganda expositions starting in the
mid 1950s America worked hard to compete
overseas with foreign powers notably
Russia the Soviet Union and China and
they began building multi-image
environments that they hoped would
democratize foreign people's I'm going
to show you one in a moment the other
way this form travels is it travels
through art world's particularly through
the new Bauhaus in Chicago and through
the new Bauhaus to the work of John
cage and through John Cage into the
first happenings of the 1960s those
happenings in turn set the stage for
Stuart brands work with the US company
and some of the world that we're sitting
in here tonight all right
propaganda first this is Moscow in 1916
1959 that's a gigantic geodesic dome
anybody remember what happened here
American National Exhibition there it is
kitchen debate you got a kitchen debate
so Khrushchev and Nixon are actually
fighting down here what happened was
this in 1980 was 57 Mudman 58 Khrushchev
was on American television being
interviewed and he lost his temper he
said alright fine I've had enough you
give me an exhibition in Manhattan I'll
give you an exhibition in Moscow and the
American propaganda enterprise and
American corporations went wild
they were psyched so we had and many of
you may not know that we had large
pictures large statues of Marx and Lenin
in Manhattan in a show that was actually
reasonably widely attended but we had
everything that we could possibly get
done in circle Mickey Park in Moscow in
1959 this is what it looked like this is
just one building it's a geodesic dome
about 200 meters across it's huge it's
golden it's designed by Buckminster
Fuller and you can see here seven
screens these are each about 35 feet
across and they're designed by the Eames
Ray and Charles Eames the Eames were
very involved in this whole whole scene
it's called glimpses of the USA and each
screen shows a different but related
single slide connected to the other
slides so I have to confess a moment of
archival pain I was at the United States
Information Agency archives in Maryland
and I found a recently Declassified
document that explained what was going
on here said this it said we need to
approach foreign peoples like a
psychotherapist we need to begin by
assessing their psychological condition
how democratic are they how free are
they
second we need to stage a communicative
intervention in order to make them more
democratic third we need to assess
whether that intervention has worked
that process starts in 1956 it reaches
its peak here
the 1959 Moscow Exhibition was designed
to give Soviet citizens the experience
of visual choice and then also through
the offerings of commercial products the
experience of consumer choice by 1959
the kind of early radical politics of
the surround had faded away
and what had taken its place was a kind
of consumerist democracy that we were
trying to export to the Soviet Union
found three other documents in the
Museum of Modern Art they were
fascinating they were actually the same
document with one line changed in each
version one was marked secret and it
said we want to build this kind of
environment the second was sorry that
was confidential the second one was
marked secret and said we want to build
this kind of environment in order to
democratize the Soviet citizens
citizenry the third document said we
want to democratize the Soviet citizenry
so that they will overthrow their
government my point here is that this is
a time when multi media seemed to
Americans multi screen media mountain
multi sound media seemed to Americans to
be tools for the overthrow of whole
totalitarian societies through the
overthrow overthrow of so totalitarian
mindsets personality is the Citadel of
resistance and if it is then what we
need to do is build systems for the
transformation of personality I mean I'm
not going to talk about the art world
tonight there's a lot about that in the
book and it's a great story so I urge
you to read him but I am gonna say this
this too is a system for the
transformation of personality
these are geodesic domes the same
technology that Buckminster Fuller used
in 1959 this time deployed in Trinidad
Colorado at drop City one of the first
and most important of the communes to
come you know when I first started
working on communes I thought geodesic
domes were something that hippies had
invented imagine my surprise when I
learned that they were in fact something
the Buc mist
fuller had patented so that he could
provide coverings for radars on the
defense early warning line I'll show you
some photos on that in a moment what's
intriguing to me here though is that the
counter culturalist have dropped city
took with them an idea from the 40s and
the idea was this if we reshape our
physical and our physical and media
environment we can become a new kind of
people and if we become a new kind of
people we can give rise to a new kind of
society alright I have to walk you back
a little bit when I stood first started
working on the Whole Earth Catalog I
believed as many do today or many did at
the time anyways that the counterculture
was a single movement Todd Gitlin the
leader of the SDS students for
Democratic Society put it this way way
back in about 1985 he said the movement
wanted to be both strategic and
expressive political and cultural to
change the world and the war win civil
rights while freeing life in the here
and now
sometimes these polls were compatible
sometimes not according to sort of you
know traditional historiography at least
by the mid eighties the counterculture
rejected mainstream society as a whole
rejected Millett the military industrial
complex and rejected technology and
technologists this is manifestly untrue
I had a very strange experience but I
guess I'll recount here I talked I was
interviewing Todd Gitlin for this book
and I said oh I'm working on this book
about Stewart brandy sauce Stewart but i
hate's to her brand
I interviewed Stewart Brand I said I
talked to Todd guiltless I don't know
about Todd Gillen what became apparent
to me just in that little interaction
but that became even more apparent to me
as I did my homework was it there were
in fact at least two countercultures one
the new left did politics to change
politics it was focused on struggle
focused on leaders and parties on
marching against the war and its signal
organization with students for a
Democratic Society on the other hand I
would argue centered here in San
Francisco was a wing of the
counterculture that I've ended up having
to give a name to and I called the new
communal
when I call them that'd be Queens
because between 1966 and 1973 was the
largest wave of commune building in all
of American history
depending on your sources somewhere
between several hundred thousand and a
million Americans began living together
communally many in rural areas as they
headed back to the land this is an
extraordinary time now the Communist
didn't last very long but they were
enormous ly influential I think the new
communalist s-- did not believe in
struggle per se rather they believed in
consciousness we need to transform
consciousness transform mindset in order
to make a new kind of society in order
to do that they wanted to adopt key
technologies produced by mainstream
society some of those you can see in the
geodesic dome but but more you can think
of LSD you can think of stereo music
they trusted not in politics but in
design design was the technique by which
we might build a better and different
world and I love saying that here you
know design is a way to model and
control a new kind of world
and in contrast to SDS its signal
organizational form was the commune now
if you're going to tackle an orthodoxy
in history you have to figure out an
alternative explanation in the orthodoxy
that I inherited was that you know the
counterculture was against technologies
of the Cold War and it's just not it's
just not so because the children of the
1950's found themselves caught between
two - sort of technological poles on the
one hand mass technology military
technology the atom bomb threatened to
destroy the world and no one who was a
child in the 50s and a young adult in
the 60s wanted to grow up to be like the
men who would destroy the world who
wanted to be dr. Strangelove nobody but
the other thing that happened in the
1950s was that we saw a flowering of
consumer technologies the 1950s was the
time when the caiway system was first
completed when the highway system was
completed it became possible to do
things like take an acid fueled road
trip
you know we could travel before but key
Z becomes Kesey in part because there's
a highway system automobiles are cheap
automobiles are cheap LSD LSD comes to
the west coast through the Veterans
Administration Hospital in Menlo Park
that's where Kesey tries it that's where
Stewart Brand tries it suddenly it
becomes available up here in the city by
the early 60s these are technologies
being produced by mainstream America for
consumption
what other technology it's really
important to simply stereo music you
know in my own life right I grew up in a
small suburban town as everyone seems to
have in this period and we had a big
family stereo the big family stereo sat
in the living room and it played
Mantovani right you always tell when the
parents were in a romantic mood because
the strings would come out you know it's
horrifying right especially to a young
teenager really no bad well um one time
for Christmas I think I was about 14 my
mother gave me my very own clothes and
play 45 45 rpm record player okay and I
took that baby into my room and I closed
the door and I put on I think it was
Jerry Lee Lewis it was just like I was
free in that space if you had grown up
with those kinds of technologies as the
children of the 50s did you wouldn't
want to abandon them and they didn't so
the children of the 1950's wanted to
start stay away from mass technology
military technology large weapon systems
large-scale technology but they
treasured small scale technology and
they treasured it in terms that were
sent by Buckminster Fuller Buckminster
Fuller was an architect a peripatetic
journalist and in 1949 I believe it was
actually for Forbes magazine he wrote an
essay about something that he called
comprehensive design and about a new
kind of person whom he called the
comprehensive designer during World War
one fuller had a daughter and he and his
wife were fairly poor they lived next to
a large naval base and their daughter
died she died of paralysis and he
believed that she had died because all
the resources needed to save her have
been directed to this naval base they
had gotten rich while he and his family
suffer and he resolved that his mission
would be to redistribute the goods of
the industrial world more equitably and
he one of the ways of the argue we
should do this was through comprehensive
design what the individual comprehensive
designer should do in Fuller's view was
identify resources from the industrial
world and then valve them down into
everyday life turn them into tools for
transforming your own local reality this
is how he expressed it it's just a wall
of text and it's so fuller right if man
is to continue as a successful pattern
complex function and universal evolution
you know this is the kind of stuff that
made sense in the 50s early 60s right
everybody was so soaked in the Cold War
and the power of science that you could
say things like this and people will go
yeah two key words here first artist
scientist the comprehensive designer was
meant to be simultaneously a creative
individual and a scientific analyst this
room I love talking about this here
because this room is devoted precisely
to artists are just like artistic
scientism scientific artistry I don't
even know what to call it but the fusion
is right here
the second piece was designed in
Fuller's view the comprehensive designer
was to leave politics out of it turn
away from politics turn away from
mainstream society let the
industrialists do what they were going
to do your job was to take industrial
products and put them to work in your
own life through a process of design you
were to design your own life one of the
signal technologies in Fuller's view for
this purpose was ultimately going to be
the geodesic dome the geodesic dome
first flourishes as a military
technology Fuller patented it in the
early 50s here it is with the Marines
practicing bringing it to the defense
early warning line which was the the
line of radar installations that
stretched across you know across Canada
toward Greenland and was to warn us
about incoming Russian bombers my point
here is that that was the geodesic dome
was
a quintessential military industrial
technology but it was also the kind of
technology that countercultural lists
could valve into their lives along the
principles of comprehensive design
remember those geodesic domes I showed
you earlier the colorful ones which are
actually kind of drawn up here in
silhouette each of those colored panels
was something that a hippie hacked out
of the roof of an automobile it was wild
when they went to drop city they went
over to junkyards and they chopped Roos
off cars five dollars a piece and then
they cut them to fit buckminster
fuller's designs and tacked them
together to make geodesic domes it was
that important to take automobiles the
industrial products of the Industrial
Age and redefine them as tools for the
transformation of consciousness you can
see that all through the comment of the
1960s this is one of my favorites this
is a commune oh gosh I have to I don't
want to get it wrong let me just quick
check yes the llama foundation this is
the llama foundation with Steve Baer in
the center there these are actually some
of Stewart brands early friends from the
art world of the 1960s who by this time
this is about 1968 have gone back to the
land and founded a commune and they're
dancing here under a geodesic dome that
they're building for world peace they
believed that the transformation of
consciousness and the use of formerly
industrial technological forms for that
purpose could remake the world
hence the Facebook hints of Facebook
we're moving now toward the present this
is Mark Zuckerberg scamp at at Burning
Man a couple years back was anyone at
Burning Man 13 anybody here go with the
shady waffle crowd okay fun yeah good
all right great good I'll watch my
tongue then thank you oh that's good
okay great but you yeah but you know
that yeah yeah okay
okay oh we can talk about that yeah so
what's intriguing to me is here's your
sister your Deezy comb at Burning Man
right in a kind of weird parti-coloured
echo of drop city you know I spent some
time at Facebook recently and I've
discovered that they even issue to
employees a copy of the button that made
Stuart brand famous Stuart brand used to
walk around with a button that said why
haven't we seen a picture of the whole
earth yet at Facebook you can get a
button that says why haven't we seen a
picture of the whole earth connected yet
they clearly Zuckerberg in particular
but others others in the tech world
clearly see themselves as descendants of
the countercultural world that I've just
described and I want to specify what
that looks like I talked a little bit
about Burning Man so about the time that
I finished the counterculture book I
went over to Google to do some work in
Google News and I walked into the main
atrium of the first building building 43
and at that time the lobby that welcome
you to the firm was decorated with
pictures of topless fire spinners from
Burning Man people doing burning my
things Burning Man artworks and I
couldn't figure this out right I have
been writing about computers in the IBM
era when if you went to the lobby
you were probably going to see a female
secretary in wool with a think thing on
her desk right with a think sign on her
desk and sort of like blonde wood in the
in the halls I was trying to figure out
how it was that what was clearly about
to become the preeminent information
firm of our era should be decorating its
welcome lobby with pictures of this
weird countercultural festival in the
desert so like any good sociologist I
went I went out to Burning Man a couple
of times let me just tell you for the
sociologists in the room you haven't
lived until your university sends you to
Burning Man with a form that your
interviewees must sign
and furthermore when your university
demands that they not that they be sober
when they sign it it's just you know
it's just things we do for science right
I mean you know okay yeah it was it was
it was kind of rough what I want to
argue what I ended up arguing in some
work I've done on Burning Man and Google
is that the mode of gathering that we
see in the desert here is a kind of
emblem of new modes of manufacturing
that are emerging across the tech
industry and migrating from the tech
industry into other spaces let me take
it a little bit slowly in the 19th
century Max Weber talked about the
Protestant ethic and how its shaped
industrial production I want to argue
that Burning Man is too contemporary new
media production what the Protestant
church was - industrial production in
the 19th century if you lived in
Pittsburgh in the 19th century you would
go to church with your other factory
mates your steel mill mates the
executives would sit up front middle
management would be right behind them
and you the workers would be in the way
back here at Burning Man if you've if
you've been away a little quick Chek how
many have actually been to the playa I
love this room thank you that's great ok
so if you've been to the playa
you know that this is a space of kind of
radical individuality and radical
collaboration people go to the playa
they buy a ticket they leave their money
ostensively mostly behind the drive out
and they work on art projects together
they work collaboratively and when they
get out there they're extraordinarily
visible to one another they can see one
another they can make art it's a weirdly
individuated and collective place it's a
place where you can build new social
networks and new technological goods at
the same time it is in many ways I would
argue a model of a project-based
technologic technology centered economy
but it's done in a spiritual idiom it's
a place to practice the deepest values
on which the engineering culture of
Google depends and it's probably for
that reason
that things like whole Earth emblems of
whole Earth ideology recur in a place
like Facebook which is otherwise a
company devoted to profiting from mass
surveillance surveillance is a kind of a
funny thing right so surveillance
applies at Burning Man to and this is
one of the things that intrigues me the
most about Burning Man Burning Man is a
Burning Man has generated more pictures
than any countercultural festival I've
ever been in I just Google up Burning
Man photo sometime and you know
mass it's just it's like your computer
will just not stop downloading um it's a
space where people watch one another to
see what one another are doing it's a
place where your individual
expressiveness is the engine of your
camps productivity and it's also the
sign of your sort of membership and
success in the system Burning Man is a
site for what I call in my in a more
sociological idiom expressive labor it's
a place where you gather to do two
things that we often think of as
opposites you gather to work and to make
physical objects like art cars that you
see here and you gather to make
community collaboration intimacy and in
that joint process you express something
that is meant to be internal and
authentic to yourself Burning Man is a
place to express one's internal self in
terms that are entirely consonant with
the new economy in technology driven
projects and colorful playful high tech
ish interaction it's a very very odd
thing I want to take the analysis just a
bit farther and I want to argue that a
lot of new firms that we give them
different names we talk about them as
Commons based firms or platform based
firms have a couple of features one
feature is they have an open platform of
some kind they have an open Commons at
Google that open Commons is is complex
it consists of the physical space of
manufacturing it also consists of
different online systems at Burning Man
the playa the dust the ground is
literally the open Commons on
which collaboration takes place at
Google your fourth if you're an engineer
you're pushed into an office with two or
three or four people usually it's kind
of cramped that's so that you meet other
people and get to know them and show
them your personality so that you can do
projects together at Burning Man you
join a camp you meet other camps you
mush up together doing projects together
and I won't I won't go too far on this
but I want to note that Burning Man and
certain tech firms yeah go for it so yes
yes right so so I love it you're you're
speaking for me no no notes notes notes
it's really good it's exactly right it
means we're communicating it's excellent
yes this is about team-building but I
would argue that it's always been about
team building and the team building
itself is actually a really it's a it's
a simultaneously instrumental and
spiritual process and that's what's so
intriguing about this new mode of
manufacturing that I'm arguing has
descended to us from the counterculture
and from the world that's around before
that this is a space where to be a whole
person is to be productive in the new
economy to be a member of a team to be
an effective member of a team requires
that you be and present yourself as an
expressive and whole person it's not
just it's not just like going drinking
with the boys used to be well you all do
something embarrassing together and then
because you can't confess it you work
better together right I mean if there's
an element of that here I mean there's
definitely an element of that here I
mean there's a lot of kind of you know
taking off your clothes wearing funny
things doing things in public that you
might not otherwise do but there's
something quite a bit deeper I
interviewed a number of folks a lot of
folks actually who build different who
built different tech projects in the
desert and what they describe is a
feeling of what I've called in other
contexts vocational ecstasy they can do
in the playa what they can't quite do it
the company the company they can work
smart they can work hard they can build
the new iPhone but in the desert
they can work with total commitment as
their whole selves for a project that
they shape and create they can
experience a kind of flow in the team
that's very hard to generate in Apple
this is what they tell me I'm thinking
actually one of the Syria developers I
interviewed it's it's really interesting
now has it become something different
than it was before
well that's that's interesting um you
know I guess I kind of think that what
we're seeing in the Burning Man of today
is what we're also seeing in the Google
of today in the Facebook of today we're
seeing worlds that have a that are
transforming the legacy the
individualist expressiveness legacy of
the counterculture and of the 40s before
that into new modes of manufacturing
through surveillance we watch one
another we see what we do we remarket
what we do we monetize what we do yeah
but within within the Facebook and
Google universe at least among engineers
not among all workers there is still a
robustly countercultural aesthetic if
you work in these firms at least in the
California offices you'll see lots of
bright colors you'll see things that are
devoted to making you creative to making
you expressive in terms that echo
without precisely repeating the
counterculture I always love the little
models that are sort of you know
hexagons agonal buck mr. foolery
I like murals bright colored paintings
Facebook actually has the analog
research lab which is something I'm
writing about now which is a kind of
almost 60 style print shop designed to
produce countercultural prints that are
propaganda to be distributed throughout
the the corporation they say things like
be open
I mean it's really complicated right be
open I want to be open I want to be open
I want to be fully myself I want to be
open with you and open with me but of
course if I'm open on Facebook that
generates a new advertising opportunity
yes
kick you a little louder please
yep yep right right yep yep yep I'd love
the way that you're expressing that
because you're saying you're kind of not
seen in the same light what's intriguing
to me about the legacy of the
counterculture in tech worlds is a
management style that manages a little
bit but lot by cool you know you know
they're smart folks and there's regular
folks right the smart folks are
engineers right the regular folks are in
marketing or worse at the call center
but none of that's codified per se I
mean it might there might be salary
differences all the rhetoric is one of
level two hierarchies and but but it's
art
right yeah no I totally agree with that
and what I'm trying to get is that
there's it's it's it's it's the the
prejudice that you're experiencing isn't
a prejudice against a function it's a
prejudice against a function expressed
as a function of your character you're
not smart the smart people are engineers
but that idea that the character could
be the center of the project that idea
is an idea that emerges in the counter
culture not necessarily in the workplace
yeah go for it
yeah very you know we've done with my
slide so he has Animal Farm
right on yep thank you that's great
that's great that I'm having this kind
of wonderful experience where you guys
are actually speaking things that are in
the back of my mind that I haven't said
it anywhere so thank you that's that's
great
all right I'm gonna wrap here fairly
quickly so I want to go back to where we
started we started with a vision of the
counterculture as a kind of colossal
Technicolor rebellion against the
industrial world emerging in the 1940s
and 50s during and after World War two
and I argued then that there was far
more continuity than change and I would
argue that even more so now I think that
the 60s brought us a kind of deeply
personal list flexible playful
expressive new society it's been
enormous ly powerful in the generation
of new identities that can be expressed
politically women's rights queer rights
racial civil rights but really more of a
50s thing but it's also brought us some
real problems this is in many ways what
the upper class looks like today it
looks like us it's mostly white it's
mostly playful it's mostly flexible it's
mostly individuated it's the kind of
people that Margaret Mead and the
committee for national morale hope to
produce through multimedia but it's also
the kind of people who formed the
communes and when they turned inward
when they turned away from politics and
toward self cultivation as a mode of
politics I would argue that that
generation left the other kinds of
people who are in the country with them
communes dropped down right in the
middle of Hispanic towns
oops our bad and we're reaping some of
the consequences of that choice today we
see it in the personalism the
commercialized personalism of Facebook
we also see it in the deep alienation of
the kinds of folks who were never
invited to communes so lest we end on a
bad note I just want to return to this
person who's a member of the [ __ ] cats
the cats were uh were still are thank
you yeah we're a wild 60s performance
troupe the same turns that I would argue
brought us the new economy and the
Facebook that we see today also brought
us a world of radical openness a world
in which it's possible to be a [ __ ] hat
and an anti-war protester and maybe
these are the kinds of people we need
now more than ever thank you
Thank You Fred we're gonna have time for
just a couple quick questions so let's
let me actually start things off so you
and I we chatted a little bit before
this and I don't know if you thought
about this question more the the my
question to you in the context of long
now is what is your doing relatively
near-term history for compared to a lot
of what we think of historian what do
you think the value of that is in the
longer frame for our farther future and
along now I guess I think two things one
the kinds of things that I'm studying
are techno cultural transformations
transformations in how we work and how
we think that are happening very rapidly
and that many ways in many ways are
accelerating processes that if you look
at them over the very long haul it gets
harder to see those kind of rapid
iterative accelerations that are
occurring in very recent time and I'm
hoping that I'm studying some of those
things one way of thinking about this
for example is I'm talking a lot about
the 60s and the counterculture but if
you gave me a 200 year window what I
would talk about are the rise of
Romantic movements of protest and their
decline their integration back into
capitalism their rise again their fall
and decline you know if you start in
these sort of 18th century you can trace
this kind of rhythmic motion and my
guess is that this rhythmic motion ends
with Facebook ok begins begins where it
begins and ends with Facebook I'm hoping
that's useful second thing that I hope
is useful is I hope that
historiographical II some of the things
that I'm doing lead to new tools and new
ways of thinking about things it's an
academic thing but it's worth knowing
that in mainstream American history
technology and media are still very much
excluded if you ask a traditional
American historian what was exciting
about the 20th century that person will
generally get all misty-eyed and say
Roosevelt okay I think Roosevelt was
tremendously important but was Roosevelt
more influential than the rise of cinema
radio television I don't know
the Internet I don't know I'm trying
very hard to kind of reintegrate the
story of the rise of particular
technologies and technology styles into
the larger history of American culture
in American social life and I think just
doing bringing those two back
together which is something that's
habitual in this room but not in the
world at large is of value so if their
questions out there Rio's gonna have the
mic for you the question I'm going to
ask get her attention and if you want
though so you you talked about it ending
at Facebook well it's obviously it's not
ending in spite what it sometimes may
feel like this week but what are your
thoughts with the variety of social
media that happened now we've see what's
happening with you know snapchat and
Instagram and then snapchat and and
other things it's changing and morphing
from what was Facebook and to other more
Beauty things do you have any thoughts
on that do you see what a trajectory is
where some of that makes sense or yeah
historians often get asked to predict
the future and I want to say that we're
just like terrible at that so I really I
really can't do that what I can do is I
can I can point to a historical irony
that's very deep and if Margaret Mead
were alive would paint her deeply the
multi media of the 1940s which were
designed very explicitly to confront
fascism and to prevent it and to promote
a particularly Democratic personality
have ironically opened the door to
Twitter into other forms through which
authoritarians as well as Democrats can
express their personalities in ways that
draw followers it's not just that
they're expressing those personalities
and ways to draw followers on Twitter
it's also that Twitter did not replace
mass media Twitter exists in a world
like all technologies do it layered up
on older technologies so there's Twitter
there's Facebook and there's still
television and cinema and newspapers and
the Trump world of expressive
personality authoritarian personality
tweets in a way that gets picked up very
rapidly in the still advertising
oriented still mass media world of
television and cinema so the Democratic
surround that was born in the 40s
neither did not replace the mass media
world of the hierarchical proto-fascist
mass media world had tried to on the
contrary in some ways I would argue it
has become an adjunct of that world and
and that's extraordinarily painful
because if you go back to the 40s they
really really really thought they could
make a new world all right question on
the stem
there's been a lot of talk in this last
week about sort of Facebook's
filter bubbles roll in this election and
I was wondering if you could just sort
of talk about that in the context of
your studies like what would think
Margaret Mead would say in sort of
looking at the situation that were in
now you know like how to create a
democratic society through media given
our issues so I think Margaret Mead
would be concerned about about bubbles
but but III think we have to be careful
I actually think that Facebook is multi
maligned on this point you know the
American right has been working very
actively for 40 years to transform our
media escape and to put it to work on
behalf of stories that it knows full
well or false in its built I mean what
Trump is saying now is stuff that the
John Birch Society was saying in the mid
50's and the John Birch Society and the
right wing around the what we now call
the alt-right has been around for a long
time and they've built real media
companies real media institutions into
which Twitter in which shape the
environment into which Twitter and
Facebook play I'm much more worried
about Fox News and its impact on public
life than I am about Facebook feeds
Facebook feeds may amplify things that
appear on Fox and they may generate
stories that appear on Fox
but Facebook's primary deleterious
effect in my view are the ways that it
helps echo what's on mass media not in
the ways that it seems to constrain
opinions to people who's already share
your own all right and we're gonna close
it there I want to say please pick with
me last advertisement back of the room
that's right we've got two books back
there by Fred and you'll be sticking
around this side talk more I want to say
a quick thank you again to the folks
that are listening on our live stream
and thanks to Edward Burtynsky in his
film Anthropocene which are sponsoring
and letting our members tune in that way
and Fred I have a little something for
you okay long now challenge coin to
carpe millennium and always to think of
us come back often please stick around
and and talk to Fred and thank you and
ground applause for frettin for you guys
thank you for being here appreciate it
[Music]